for some reason my Twitter mentions
became filled with people upset over
something that I tweeted on March 8th
2018. and here's the offending tweet
video games are a sacred cow because our
country is filled with adults who are
obsessed with them that's why we all
pretend insanely that there's nothing
wrong with or disturbing about a child
spending all day killing people in a
virtual world shocking stuff apparently
in 2018 I made the provocative claim
that children shouldn't spend all day
playing violent video games if you guys
have a problem with that
fight me lots of people apparently
disagree they I guess think that
children should spend all day playing
violent video games I mean I could see a
response where you say well no no kids
played spending all day playing violent
video games but to respond like you
disagree with the statements is another
thing entirely but that's what happened